- Hi!
- First of all, I haven't
seen you since your haircut.
It looks amazing!
- Thank you.
- Oh my God.
How wonderful is that?
- Thank you.
- To just take a shower
and get out and it's like-
- I will tell you it is so nice
because my hair air dries-
- Yes!
- Really well.
Like it was cut really well.
And I just, I spend like
zero time on my hair now.
Its so nice.
- Oh, my God.
And it looks so hot.
Oh, that's great for you.
- Thank you! Thanks.
(audience cheering)
- Well wait, in that clip we just saw,
we just saw you looking for aliens.
- Yes.
- So have you seen an alien?
Have you ever had an experience?
- I have never seen an ET face to face,
but I have seen a lot of
weird things in the sky
that can't be explained
and even on the ground.
- Nope.
- Yes
- No, but you did hypnotherapy
and I've always wanted to do it
for like separate reasons,
but like you did hypnotherapy
to learn more about the encounter,
right?
- Yes.
- Did you have a crazy
experience doing it?
- I didn't have like a
crazy experience doing it,
but I think doing it for this,
I did it for a crazy experience
that I had.
- Yeah.
- I had a night where I was dreaming
and I say dreaming very loosely
because I don't really know what happened,
but I, all of a sudden was in my room
and I know I said,
(Demi stuttering)
I sound, I sound,
like this is gonna sound so out there,
but just bear with me.
So I woke up in my room and
there was like three beings.
And then they were like-
- No.
- Do you wanna see your planet?
And I was like, (beep) oh, sorry.
(everyone laughing)
Sorry.
- You were like, hell yeah!
- I was like, hell yeah! Let's go!
(audience applauding)
So I like whooshed out of my room
and was like hovering over the planet.
And then all of a sudden they're like,
you wanna see our planet?
And I was like,
hell yeah!
- Hell yeah!
(audience laughing)
- Then I wooshed to this like pink
and purple planet that
I've never seen, but.
And then-
- What?
- So that with the hypnotherapy,
I was like, trying to figure
out what exactly that was.
Was it like,
I don't want to use the word abduction
because that implies that
it wasn't with consent.
I was totally for it.
(audience laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
- You said hell yes.
(women laughing)
- So I can't call it like an abduction.
I called it an astral
projection for a long time
'cause I went somewhere else.
- Yeah.
- But then I realized maybe
this was just an encounter
that I had.
- Yeah.
- And I talk about that on the show.
- Well, it's so funny that
you're talking about this
'cause is stuff like that real
or is it you're just like so vulnerable
and your walls are down
and you're so like,
I sound like a stoner.
(Demi laughing)
I'm not a stoner.
(audience applauding)
I just mean like,
it was interesting watching this show
'cause I was like, wait.
So maybe it's like, it
really doesn't allow you,
'cause this one character ends up
actually letting their walls down
and like, and in you're like,
well maybe that's what
they really are feeling
and they just weren't able to feel that
and it's really real.
So I dunno, I'm not against all
of it being real.
- Yeah
- I'm just terrified of it being real.
(Kelly laughing)
- I think there's a
common misunderstanding
that these beings are bad
because of all the movies
that we've seen-
- Yeah, like sharks.
- "Independence Day" or-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, or like sharks.
- It's like we do
with sharks, yeah. You make 'em horrible.
They're, yeah.
- Yes but I think-
- [Kelly] They've been here longer.
- I think that they've been here longer
and I think that, oh,
you're talking about sharks.
- Yeah.
- I'm talking-
(everyone laughing)
- I was like, you're totally right.
They've been here longer.
- I feel like, am I stoned right now?
(everyone laughing)
No.
I'm not.
- But when I think that
they're just looking out
for the wellbeing of humanity.
Like I think that they're-
- Well, I'll take that.
- Yeah.
- I think we need all the help we can get.
- We do.
- Amen.
(audience applauding)
Well, this new show is about looking
for extra terrestrial life though, right?
- Yes.
- So here's my thing
and I always ask like anybody on here
that's into aliens or anything like that.
Like do you, I think that what we think,
like you said movies,
we picture like big
heads and like green men-
- Yeah.
- And like all that stuff.
But it could, I think it's gonna
be something completely different.
Like, than that.
Like, you know, it could be even something
like so micro that, you know,
we can't see it or whatever,
but like something exists.
Like I feel.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Right. I just think that
it's kind of self-centered to have a view
that we're the only life in the universe.
- That's so human, right?
- You know.
Its so human.
- It's just us.
- Of course we think
that we're the only ones.
- Yeah.
- I just, I think the universe
is way too big for that.
- Yeah. I think so too,
to limit it to that.
I agree, I agree.
- Yeah.